four years ago this man was paralyzed in
a fall even today his spinal cord is too
badly damaged to transmit signals from
his brain to his limbs and yet he can
walk by using the power of the mind and
a 65 kilo exoskeleton what was performed
was movements of an avatar on-screen and
an exoskeleton in all four limbs and
that's new it's never been done from the
brain controlling all four limbs so
that's exciting for this domain of
research the test subjects name is Tebow
a 28 year old French optician two years
ago back in 2017 the researchers
implanted two sensors in t-bo's skull
either side of the sensory motor cortex
that's the part of the brain which
controls movement the electrodes detect
t-bo's brain signals and then a computer
algorithm processes those signals and
within 350 milliseconds the algorithm
translates the brain's electrical
impulses directly into this mechanical
suit the exoskeleton tebow moves
literally using the power of his mind
first he practiced on controlling a
computer avatar now he's learned to move
all four limbs of the exoskeleton suit
this may look slow and unsteady but in
technological terms it's a massive leap
forward the french scientists behind
this exoskeleton were not available for
interview on friday an official media
launch takes place next week
exoskeletons are not new robotic
mobility assistance has been developing
rapidly in recent years but experts say
that harnessing brain power is still in
its infancy people with very high levels
of tetraplegia are able to control for
example electric wheelchairs by puffing
and sucking with a device now so if this
brain implant is really to transform
that and bring the promise of people by
their thoughts controlling their
mobility in their environment it's got a
long way to go
the road ahead may be long but every
journey begins with a single step
Paul Brennan al-jazeera